calmez vous monsieur le président
calmez-vous c'est pas beau bourg de
santé calmez vous dès que vous prononcez
le nom de françois rebsamen vous devenez
thon rouge et vous vous excitez bonne
ambiance au conseil départemental
colette popard plus que jamais remonté
contre françois sauvadet le président du
conseil départemental vient de proposer
au vote
un protocole d'accord sur le transfert
de certaines de ses compétences vers la
métropole
pour le groupe d'opposition proche de
françois rebsamen
ce protocole n'est plus d'actualité
puisque les élus métropolitains n'ont
pas eu suffisamment d'information
accepté il nous manque des données
chiffrées des données rh des données
financières pour faire une analyse
contradictoire avant de signer cet
accord et vous le savez très bien
vous vous êtes engagés à nous donner à
donner justement ces données au 18 mars
et on voit bien encore votre capacité
d'obstruction puisque nous les avons eus
qu'en fin de semaine le 23 au coeur du
débat le transfert à la métropole sur
son territoire de compétence jusqu alors
gérée par le département
voir id touristes mais surtout
l'accompagnement social et là la guerre
des chefs entre françois rebsamen et
françois sauvadet semble déclaré le
maire de dijon est le seul en france il
ne veut pas d'accord avec le département
comme il le seul en france à avoir
expressément revendiquer toutes les
compétences prévues par la loi
un protocole d'accord dans l'impasse
depuis près de deux ans mais après un
premier report le temps presse les deux
collectivités doivent se mettre d'accord
avant le 31 mars
au-delà de cette date le préfet
tranchera ou laissera un nouveau sursis